the triangle shape freaks me out because
it's like Illuminati what's up guys my
name is Hal I make videos here at
BuzzFeed in New York and today we are
trying the Taco Bell chicken nugget in
my head Taco Bell and chicken nuggets
don't go together but they're here so
I'm gonna go in the office and see what
our BuzzFeed staffers have to say I'm
all about this idea love Taco Bell love
chicken nuggets they kind of look like
Doritos so it's kind of sketchy nice
like meat triangle I have here gonna dip
it into this yellow goop and I'm pretty
excited about it let's eat this food do
I have to do this yeah okay how would
you describe the flavor it tastes like
those like dinosaur nuggets that you get
is a little kid hmm I don't do it are
yours good the flavor is very chicken
nugget II you know I like this involves
all right do you like the cheese dipping
sauce it's really cheesy I don't know if
I like any cheese like a pea sauce it's
a classic like fake cheese which you
can't go wrong with with the nacho
cheese it tastes like a chicken nugget
nacho which is it's a euphoric
experience on to say and the cheese
confuses me free drop that's in the
shape of a triangle I don't like that
it's in the shape of a triangle because
it reminds me of a Dorito so then when
I'm putting it in my mouth I really want
to taste like nacho cheese or Ito's or
something good the shape is interesting
I think it's just like separate self in
the competition tastes like what it
looks like which is a triangle-shaped
meat kind of get what you expect out of
it I like that it's thin so I wouldn't
feel as bad if I ate like a million of
them how would you rank evidence other
chicken I keep my I would rank this well
above other chicken nuggets I think but
then again I love Taco Bell compared to
other chicken nuggets have had in the
past I would say it's about on par
around McDonald's around that level I
think is
right around there um yeah I'm just I'm
really disturbed all around by just not
kid it tastes like a chicken triangle it
tastes not of this earth I would say
it's pretty comparable to all the other
chicken nuggets they'll find it's the
same to me my mouth is very happy right
now and I would definitely buy this I'd
talk about I feel like if I was drunk
and I just wanted some chicken nuggets I
would do it I honestly thought it was
gonna not taste good at all because
they're not really known for chicken
nuggets ten out of ten would recommend
this the only time I would see myself
eating this is if I was peer pressured
at my office to do this on camera I
can't wait to see other shapes of
chicken maybe a chicken rhombus chicken
isosceles triangle the equilateral
triangle right here I'd like to see no
sauce please maybe someday
pretty exciting times